Some celebrities seem to never leave home without their BFF.
Courtney Cox and Jennifer Aniston's friendship is always on display...
...whether it's on-screen or on vacation.
Selena Gomez and Taylor Swift certainly heart each other,...
...showing the love at this year's Billboard Music Awards.
Tina Fey and Amy Poehler kept their real-life bestie banter going...
...when they co-hosted the Golden Globes earlier this year.
But best friends aren't just for girls.
"Jersey Shore" stars Vinny and Pauly D practically defined the term "bromance."
Although Adam Levine and Blake Shelton of NBC's "The Voice"...
...seemed to be right on their heels.
What about some lesser-known celebrity best friends?
Gwyneth Paltrow says Cameron Diaz holds her hand while she gets waxed.
And Rihanna and Katy Perry admit to calling each other...
...to coordinate outfits before award shows.